The DC Comics Character Who Gained His Powers
from Cocaine
Comics are littered with weird and obscure
heroes and villains with powers that range
from the mundane to the ridiculous, but there’s
one character that ranks among the most “interesting”
ever conceived- Snowflame, a villain with
powers that were intrinsically linked to the
character taking copious amounts of cocaine.
As the character himself explained in the
comic, “I am Snowflame, every cell of my
being burns with white hot ecstasy.
Cocaine is my god!
And I am the human instrument of its will!”
Snowflame was conceived as a villain by DC
writer Steve Englehart for an incredibly short-lived
comic series called “The New Guardians”,
appearing in just one of the series’ eventual
12 total issues.
The New Guardians were a superhero team comprised
of some of DC’s more obscure heroes and,
according to the first issue, were specifically
chosen to be an accurate representation of
the various segments of the human race.
It was also noted that the ultimate goal of
the New Guardians was to pass on their genetically
superior genes to the next generation.
Notable DC superheroes given the honour of
becoming a New Guardian included a flamboyant,
silk robe wearing gay Peruvian magician called
Extraño, a disembodied Australian woman who
exists in “aboriginal Dreamtime”, a Japanese
man who is comprised of electronics and who
interact with various electronic devices,
and an Inuit who had the power of bringing
out the best in people…
(I can’t make this stuff up.)
ExtrañoDespite the laudable attempt on DC’s
part to make the heroes as diverse as possible,
and even an earnest attempt to include a superhero
gay character in the form of Extraño (ahead
of its time in this way in the 1980s), the
comic seemed tone-deaf even by that decade’s
comic standards.
In regards to Extraño specifically, because
DC couldn’t outright say he was gay due
to publishing standards of the time, they
resorted to tired homosexual stereotypes to
imply it as bluntly as possible, and even
had him being attacked by The Hemogoblin so
that Extraño would contract HIV…
The comic also left it unclear whether Extraño
already had HIV when he was attacked by said
supervillain…
Supposedly the idea behind the comic was to
use lesser known heroes to explore contemporary
themes such as drugs and sexuality, but editors
found it too risqué and quickly quashed the
comic after the 12th issue.
As for Snowflame, he appeared in the second
issue of New Guardians, being portrayed as
a Colombian drug lord who the New Guardians
attempt to defeat to quell the flow of drugs
from the region.
Because subtlety wasn’t exactly the name
of the game with this line of comics, the
issue is titled, “Jungle Snow”.
In his first encounter with the New Guardians,
Snowflame mocks the newly formed superhero
team before proclaiming “Cocaine is my god”.
He then slaps a member of the team called
Ram- the aforementioned Japanese man who has
the power of electronics…
Snowflame then proceeds to elaborate somewhat
on the nature of his powers.
He notes that he exudes a constant aura of
fire while acting under the influence of cocaine
and that the drug similarly increases his
strength, durability and fighting prowess
to extreme levels, while also making him impervious
to pain- the more cocaine he snorts, the greater
the effect.
When the Guardians ask him to surrender, he
laughs in their faces, noting his love of
cocaine, “Give up?
Give up the ultimate exhilaration, the divine
rapture, the euphoria of electricity that
now surges through every molecule of my body?”
Snowflame then calls for his men, who are
also coked out of their minds, to shoot the
New Guardians with guns and bury them fully
clothed in shallow graves, prompting one of
the characters to have a flashback to the
aftermath of their fight with The Hemogoblin,
which features several pages of surprisingly
accurate information about AIDS.
Yes, it’s hard to believe they decided to
make Batman movies instead of New Guardians.
The comic then flashes back to the present
and shows that the New Guardians were merely
pretending to be dead; how they survived being
shot is never elaborated upon.
They then track down Snowflame who is found
lounging around with several women in bikinis,
bragging about how much cocaine he’s going
to sell, when they confront him and offer
him the chance to surrender.
Snowflame grabs a huge handful of cocaine
and shoves it directly into his own face.
He then commands his bodyguards, who are inexplicably
all wearing swimwear and also strung out on
cocaine, to attack.
During the battle, Floronic Man, who has the
power of plants, discovers that he can absorb
the cocaine from people’s bodies and uses
this knowledge to slowly drain all the cocaine
from the bodies of Snowflame’s guards.
Snowflame himself is then punched into a shed
full of chemicals, which due to his fiery
cocaine aura, instantly explodes, presumably
killing him.
The character is never mentioned again.
The late 1980s were a different time
DC Comics wasn’t the only ones coming up
with oddball superheroes.
Marvel Comic’s “Squirrel Girl” was a
high school student who could control squirrels
and used them to fight villains.
She also had a 3-4 foot tail, buck teeth,
claws (and retractable knuckle-spikes a-la
Wolverine), and lips that tasted like hazelnuts…
She wanted desperately to be Iron Man’s
sidekick, but he rejected her, even after
she saved his life- though he did tell her
that when she was older, perhaps she could
join the Avengers.
“Zeitgeist” was another “odd” Marvel
character.
After finding out he had super stomach acid,
he naturally decided to use it to fight evil.
How did he find out about his super power?
After getting drunk and making out with a
girl, he fell ill and vomited all over her,
burning the poor girl’s face and disfiguring
her.
(Who hasn’t seen that scenario play out?)
His response to the incident- “I sure hope
the doctors managed to give her back her pretty
face.”
The good news is that Zeitgeist now realized
he had a super power and began using it for
good by vomiting all over the bad guys.
His stomach acid was so potent, that it could
burn through a 4 inch thick steel plate in
half a minute.
I’m just guessing with that on her face,
the girl did not get her face back.
Another bizarre character was “Rainbow Girl”,
a DC Comics character who controlled the powers
of the emotional spectrum, which would give
her extremely unpredictable mood swings.
Essentially, Rainbow Girl’s superpower was
almost explicitly a raging case of PMS…
To fight evil, Rainbow Girl would tap her
anger (the color red), hope (blue) and willpower
(green).
She also had the ability to create a pheromone
field that gave her a personality that everyone
loved and no one could resist.